Last time we finished up breaking up HTML and JavaScript into tokens.
We'd specified them by regular expressions,
which are implemented by finite state machines.
And this has always been one of my favorite parts of programming languages,
and it actually sticks in my mind when I was a student
taking this in a more traditional classroom,
the instructor asked after talking about regular expressions in lexing
"Is there anyone interested in doing research?"
And this was actually my first step towards becoming a professor,
but actually, I was doing really poorly in the class at the time.
I was not a very good student,
so I went to the professor's office.
He said, "Show up if you want to do undergraduate research."
I was there, and when I came in the door, there was a second
where I could see in his eyes this "You? Not you."
But then he quickly sort of changed to a more positive attitude,
and I continued to work with him, and that began my career
pushing forth the boundaries of human knowledge
by studying programming languages.
And to some degree, what I want you to take away from a story like this
is it's not necessary to have mastered these concepts
right at the beginning or the first time you see them.
What I really want is for you to master these concepts by the end of the course,
so don't feel too bad if the original units have been giving you a bit of difficulty.
They gave me a lot of difficulty when I learned them the first time.
We finished up with regular expressions, and this time we're going to move on to
context-free grammars, the sentences of programming languages.
Let's get started.